Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Cümleten merhaba.
Tabii bizim gibi biraz
hayatın arkasında olan insanlar
böyle kalabalıklarda
ne kadar güzel konuşur bilmiyorum ama
bugün anlamlı bir günde
ben de size anlamlı bir şeyler
söylemeye çalışacağım.
Biliyorsunuz, bugün 23 Nisan:
Ata'nın, geleceğimizi
emanet ettiği çocukların da bayramı.
Aslında, ben o gidilmeyen yollara
beni hazırlayan çocukluğumu
anlatacağım sizlere
çünkü hayat bir prospektüs değil.
"Ben bunu yaptım,
alın siz de bunu yapın" diye
kimseye veremiyoruz maalesef.
Yaptıklarımız,
kendi deneyimlerimizle elde
ettiklerimiz bilgilerle yapabiliyoruz.
Bazen bilgiyi biliyoruz,
ama bilgiye sahip olamıyoruz.
O tabii bizi hayallerimizden
çok uzağa taşıyor.
Ben de size böyle
çok uzun uzun laflar yapmayıp
biraz çocukluğuma götürmek isterim.
Vallahi 10 yaşına kadar;
elektriği, suyu,
yolu olmayan bir köyde doğdum ben.
Annemin babamın
İstanbul'da olmasına karşılık,
dedeme oyuncak olarak verilmiştim
ve orada mutlu bir çocuk olarak
hayata başladım.
Dedemin şömineli bir odası vardı
ve orada duvara asılı
kocaman bir dünya haritası vardı.
Eskiden böyle bez haritalar vardı;
kaldırdığınız zaman,
ışığa tuttuğunuzda arkasından
dünyaya bakabilme şansınız vardı.
İlk hayallerimi orada kurmaya başlamıştım.
Orada daha
dört tekerlekli arabalara binmeden,
dünyanın her yerindeki
birçok yeri hayal edebiliyor,
isimlerini hafızama kazıyabiliyordum.
Daha da, daha da güzeli
babamın, dedemin kütüphanesine getirdiği
bir Kaptan Memo çizgi romanı vardı.
Orada bir tane Nautilus vardı,
Nautilus benim için acayip hayal gemisiydi
ve o Nautilus'un dünya seyahatlarini
okuyabileyim diye
daha okula gitmeden okuma yazmayı da
öğrenmiştim kendi hâlimde.
Bir gün, babaannemin
büyük bir peynir kabı vardı.
O kabı indirdim bahçenin ortasına
ve dedim ki
"Ben bunu Nautilus yapacağım,"
çünkü bizim bahçenin
hemen altında koca bir göl vardı.
O kabı oraya yuvarlayıp,
onu denizaltı yapıp
oradan dünyaya açılacağımı sanıyordum.
Böyle mutlu mesut oynarken
bir kış günüydü,
dedem beni çağırdı.
Dedi ki, "Cemal" dedi,
iki tane yumurta tutuyordu elinde.
"Şunları al," dedi.
"Koy ceplerine."
Koydum.
Şimdi bizim böyle bir avuç içi gibi
Boğaziçi diye bir köyde yaşıyoruz.
"Karşı mahallelerdeki komşuları
akşam yemeğe davet edeceksin," dedi
mevlüdümüz var.
"Eğer bu yumurtaları kırmadan
buraya gelirsen, dönersen;
ne dilersen, o gerçekleşecek."
Ki dedem benim için idol,
bir şey söylüyor ve söylediği şey de
hayatın sihirli değneğini bana veriyor:
Yani iki tane yumurta.
"Yani dede," dedim,
"ben şimdi bu iki yumurtayı kırmadan
buraya dönersem, ne istersem olacak mı?"
"Kesinlikle olur," dedi.
Şimdi bir çocuğun
hayal dünyasında, cebinde
dilediği bir şeyi gerçekleştirecek
iki tane çiğ yumurta var
ve gerçekten dağ yolları,
orman, çalı, çırpı, dere tepe...
Bu yumurtaları kırmadan
gidip davetini yapıp eve gelecek
ve ben bunu başardım.
Sonra yumurtaları getirip dedeme verdim.
Eline koydum,
"Bak kırmadım yumurtaları" dediğimde
aslında dedemin benim kafamı gözümü
kırmamamı sağlamak için,
beni kontrol etmek için o yumurtaları
cebime koyduğunu öğrendiğimde
60 yaşlarına yaklaşıyordum.
(Kahkaha) (Alkış)
Bir gün,
dedemin o haritasında,
dünyanın her yerinde isimler vardı
ve bütün çizgiler böyle
dünyanın üstünde bir yere doğru gidiyordu.
Hep merak ediyordum, bu niye bütün yollar
dünyanın üstüne doğru gidiyor diye.
Dedeme her sorduğumda,
"Herhâlde kimse gitmemiş o tarafa"
diye cevap alıyordum.
Dedemin avucuna yumurtaları koyarken
de bir gün oraya yürümeyi dilemiştim,
orasının ne olduğunu bilmeden.
Sonra bir gün,
bir Rus MO26 helikopterinden
buza indiğimizde
ve Kuzey Kutbu'na doğru
gitmeye başladığımda,
istem dışı ağlıyordum
çünkü hakikaten,
o iki yumurtanın onu gerçekleştirdiğini
düşünüyordum ve o gün dedim ki,
"Keşke o yumurtalar şimdi elimde olsa
tek bir şey isterdim:
Dedemin o şömineli odasının
hiç değişmeden orada kalmasını."
Yine hani niye dedemin şömineli odasının
değişmemesini istediğimle ilgili
güzel bir örneğim daha var:
Bir gün, dedemin arıları vardı
ve çocuktum, 4 yaşında filan
ve çok hiperaktif bir çocuktum.
Bir gün arılara gidiyorduk
ve böyle koca bir düzün ortasında,
şimdiki sizler gibi
böyle binlerce papatya...
Dedem tam o düzün ortasında durdu,
şimdi benim kırmızı halıda durduğum gibi.
"Oğlum bak bakalım
bu düzde ne görüyorsun?" dedi.
Baktım, baktım, baktım...
Ne gördüysem saydım
ve o değil, bu değil, bu değil...
Dedem, "Başka ne görüyorsun?"
Başka hiçbir şey görmüyordum.
Akşam gittik biz,
arıları toparladık işimizi,
geldik yine aynı yerde durdu
ve "Oğlum bak bakalım
ne görüyorsun?" dedi.
Bir baktım, düzdeki yeşillik
sabahkinden daha fazla fark ediliyor.
"Aa dede," dedim
"papatyalar kapılarını kapatmış."
"Bak oğlum" dedi,
"esas ben de onu merak ediyorum" dedi,
"akşam olunca bu çiçeklerin kapısını
kim kapatıyor acaba?" diye.
Sonraki bir hafta boyunca
bir papatyanın başında oturup
gerçekten onların kapısını
kim kapatıyor diye merak etmiştim.
Şimdi,
hayat bizi hep meraklarımız
güzel yerlere taşır.
Merak edebilecek fırsatları
yaratabildiğimizde,
hayatı da değiştirme şansını
yakalıyoruz aslında.
Ben
kendi adıma gitmek istediğim
bütün yollara gidilmesi,
hatta gidilmesini hayal edilmeyen
yollara gidebildiğimi düşünüyorum
ve bütün bu düşündüğüm, gidebildiğim,
bütün bu başarının temelinde
gerçekten çocukken kurduğum hayallerin
hiç de küçümsenmeyecek
boyutta olduğunu biliyorum.
Çocukluktan sonra
hiç hayal kurmadım hemen hemen,
sadece hayallerime yürüdüm,
sadece o kurduğum hayaller gelişti.
Belki de 23 Nisan Çocuk Bayramı,
çocukların egemenlik üzerine
bir bayrama atfedilmesinin temeli
aslında burada saklı.
Yani Ata ne kadar öngörülü bir adammış ki
çocuklara neyi emanet etmiş,
çocuklara neyi yüklemiş!
Yine yaylada 15 tane ineğimiz var
ve ben çobana gidiyorum,
çocuğum daha ilkokul 3.-4. sınıfta filan,
her gün onların sorumluluğu...
Geliyoruz, onlar ahıra girdiğinde
ben de, evimin önünden bir dere geçiyor,
orada oyun oynuyorum.
Akşam olduğunda
herkesin babaannesi çağırıyor,
işte bir tane Muzaffer diye bir arkadaşım
var, onu çağırıyor ben kalıyorum yalnız!
Benim babaannem beni çağırmıyor.
Allah Allah diyorum,
babaannem beni niye sevmiyor,
herkesin babaannesi onu çağırıyor
ama beni çağırmıyorlar eve.
Bir gün, beni banyo yaptırıyor.
Dedim babaanne...
Babaanne demiyoruz tabii,
ben şimdi burada naziklik olsun diye
babaanne diyorum,
ebe deriz biz yaşlı hani
babamızın annesine.
"Ebe," dedim,
"sen beni hiç mi sevmiyorsun?"
"Niye, nereden çıktı oğul?" dedi.
"Ee" dedim, "herkesi Laz ebe çağırır
Muzaffer'i, o onu çağırır...
Sen beni hiç çağırmıyorsun!"
Durdu, "oğul" dedi "beni çağıran mı var ki
eve gel işte böyle.
Sen de eve girecek zamanını
kendin bilmiyor musun ki
ben seni çağırayım da sen eve gelesin."
O günde anlamadığımız şey, o gün
anlayamadığım, sevgisizliğe yorduğum şey;
aslında bir çocuğa verilmek istenen
öz güvenin, sorumluluğun ta da kendisiydi.
Bugün hepimizin, bir çoğumuzun çocuğu
hemen yanı başımızdaki küçücük odada
belki de sanal bir dünyaya adım atarken
gerçek dünyayla hiç yüzleşmeden
yaşamaya yaşlanmaya devam ediyor.
Aslında hepimizin
bunda sorumluluğu çok büyük.
Ben her şeyden vazgeçip
oturabilecek bir hâldeyken
oturmayışımın sebebi de bu,
çünkü onlara hayal kuracakları
doğru misyon,
doğru insanları göstermek zorundayız.
Onlara hayal kurabilecekleri
içerikleri vermek zorundayız.
Eğer vermezsek
gerçekten bir geleceğimiz olmayacak,
bir gelecek kuramayacağız
ve bugünkü çocuklar yarın,
on sene sonra,
bugün 10 yaşındaki çocuk
yarın 10 sene sonra 20 yaşında
başa çıkamayacağımız bir güç olarak
karşınızda duruyor olacak.
O zaman hayatımızı değiştirmek istiyorsak,
gidilmesi gerekmeyen, gidilmeyen yollara
gitmekten imtina etmeyecek çocuklar,
hayal kurmaktan imtina etmeyecek çocuklar
ve mutlaka öz güveni yüksek çocuklar
yaratmak zorundayız.
Bizler bir seyahate çıkarken
dönmemeyi göze alarak yola çıkarız.
Bunu hiç latife etmiyorum,
en ufak seyahatimizde bile
temel kural budur.
Benimle yola çıkacak arkadaşlara
bunu çok net söylerim.
"Dostlar bizler -mış gibi yapmayız,
bizzat hayatın içinde olmayı
ve hayatta kalmayı
becererek yapmak istediklerimize ulaşırız,
eğer dönmeyi düşünüyorsanız,
döneceğinizi de düşünüyorsanız
bir daha düşünün,
çünkü ben dönmemek üzere
yola çıkıyorum," derim.
Çünkü hayat size bahşedilmiş
ve ne zaman biteceği zaten belli değil,
düşünsenize istediğiniz bir yola
istediğiniz bir yolculuğa çıkmışken
hayatınız son bulmuş,
bundan güzel bir şey mi olur!
(Alkış)